we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors magic spoon is the cereal that
tastes
exactly like the delicious cereals from
your childhood except it has no sugar
tons of protein and only three net carbs
so it's perfect for a keto
diet to get free shipping go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman nebia is
a revolutionary showerhead that saves
you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded
person by letting you read or listen to
an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
well donald trump threatened to do it it
was sort of confusing
why he was threatening to do it but he
did it donald trump has vetoed the
second
coronavirus relief package that got
through the house and senate
and now there are immediately a number
of important things here and let me get
to what for many people is the most
pressing and important question does
this mean
that if you were expecting a six hundred
dollar check
uh if you make up to seventy five
thousand dollars a year that you will
not be getting your 600
and the answer is we can't say that yet
because this may be
the first time that during donald
trump's presidency the house and senate
are going to override donald trump's
veto
remember that if a president vetoes a
bill passed by the house and senate the
house and senate can override that with
a two-thirds vote
in the house and a two-thirds vote in
the senate and that may well
happen reports are that the house will
vote
on monday and if the house votes to
override the senate will reconvene on
tuesday to vote as well now the
explanation for why trump vetoed this
bill
is actually sort of incoherent donald
trump with his veto
notice saying quote my administration
has
taken strong actions to help keep our
nation safe and support our service
members
i will not approve this bill which would
put the interests of the washington dc
establishment over those of the american
people now what trump
seems to be referring to here is what he
mentioned on tuesday in that very
strange speech he gave where
he listed countries and other
environmental and
and other causes that were receiving
money
but they were actually receiving the
money from the spending bill not the
covet bill but they were passed
together reminder of that from donald
trump's tuesday video
this bill contains 85.5 million dollars
for assistance to
cambodia 134 million dollars to burma
1.3 billion dollars for egypt
and the egyptian military which will go
out and buy
almost exclusively russian military
equipment
25 million dollars for democracy and
gender programs in pakistan
505 million dollars to belize costa rica
el salvador guatemala
honduras nicaragua and panama
40 million dollars for the kennedy
center in washington dc
which is not even open for business one
billion dollars for the smithsonian
and an additional 154 million dollars
for the national gallery of art
likewise these facilities are
essentially
not open seven million dollars for reef
fish
management 25 million dollars to combat
asian carp 2.5 million dollars to count
the number of amberjack fish
in the gulf of mexico a provision to
promote the breeding of fish
in federal hatcheries three million
dollars in poultry production technology
two million dollars to research the
impact of downed trees
566 million dollars for construction
projects at the fbi so there are about
three to four ways in which this is
incoherent first of all
the money trump is talking about is in
the spending bill to keep government
open
which was passed alongside the covet
bill
as an omnibus bill so it is true that
these things were voted on together it
is not true that the covet bill
includes the things that donald trump is
mentioning but then adding
as a next layer to this incoherence
the spending bill which trump is
referencing
contains basically the same or less
money
than what trump asked for in his own
budget just some months ago
trump asked for the money in the
spending bill that he now vetoed
which is not actually part of the covet
bill they were simply put together for a
vote which i'm against doing to be clear
uh trump also said 600 isn't enough and
he wants two thousand dollars during
that tuesday speech
congress found plenty of money for
foreign countries lobbyists and special
interests
while sending the bare minimum to the
american people
who need it it wasn't their fault it was
china's fault not their fault i am
asking congress to amend this bill and
increase the
ridiculously low six hundred dollars
to two thousand dollars or four thousand
dollars
for a couple i'm also asking congress to
immediately get rid of the wasteful and
unnecessary items
from this legislation so once again i
agree with trump
but many democrats have been talking
about two thousand dollars
since may and it's been trump's
republican party that's been against
more money now trump says he wants more
well it would have been nice for him to
push for that
and lobby for that in may when some
democrats wanted it but republicans by
and large don't
but don't want more money it's just up
and down erratic
one way one way or the other and then of
course
deep down there may be other reasons not
being mentioned for donald trump's veto
one is that the spending bill doesn't
eliminate
section 230. trump has been obsessed
with this section 230
says that if people post things that are
legally problematic to twitter
the people are responsible or liable not
twitter if people do the same thing with
youtube or facebook
it's the user's not the platform
responsible trump believes
that if you get rid of section 230 and
make the platforms legally responsible
lots of anti-trump stuff would be taken
down
trump's just wrong about that he just
misunderstands and then trump
also is essentially defunding the troops
in vetoing this bill
while he claims to be the biggest
supporter who has funded them more than
anybody else ever has
and then lastly it also appears trump
didn't like some of the anti-money
laundering provisions that are in
the spending bill not the covid bill and
we recently learned
that jared kushner has been running a
shell company
to siphon campaign donations off
and pay salaries to trump's own family
members and friends
so there's incoherence there's likely
a self-serving aspect there's really a
little bit of everything here
in the end the mediocre bill will
probably pass as the house and senate is
expected
to override trump's veto next week again
if all goes as it is
expected to go the trump crony
pardon list is growing quickly i had 15
or so names for you yesterday that were
moderately cronyistic but today's list
while smaller
is way more cronyistic donald trump has
now pardoned
jared kushner's dad charles kushner
remember
trump's daughter is ivanka ivanka
married to jared
jared is not just trump's son-in-law but
also an advisor
and jared's dad charles kushner was
previously convicted for
hiding personal political contributions
through organizations
for tax evasion and for witness
tampering it's quite a slate of crimes
and the witness tampering charge is wild
jared kushner's dad charles kushner
hired a prostitute that he knew what it
means that he knew her
it's not clear he knew a prostitute
hired her
to seduce his own brother-in-law set up
a recording system for the whole thing
and then sent the tape to his sister
he was ultimately sentenced for two
years served 14 months
then went to a halfway house and was
disbarred big fiasco
so trump pardoned him essentially a
family member
by marriage trump also pardoned paul
manafort
and roger stone both convicted in the
trump-russia investigation
both quote stayed loyal as they say
didn't give up any info on trump so they
got pardoned specifically
after helping to keep donald trump out
of harm's way
exactly as we thought they would when
stone and manafort got pulled into the
investigation years ago
and then less prominently trump added
uh pardons for 23 other people yesterday
and
three sentence commutations as well so
are we surprised that donald trump is
pardoning friends and cronies
no of course not is there a bigger
question about presidential pardons that
goes beyond trump
no doubt no doubt about it but the way
that donald trump is using his pardon
power is so cronyistic
that even some republicans are saying
this is not good um
republican senator ben sasse from
nebraska said quote
this is rotten to the core now to
everybody
saying to me on twitter and elsewhere
that hold on a second obama also
pardoned people
yes obama pardoned many people but
there's a key difference
which is that so far the majority of
trump's pardons
are either people directly connected to
him or whose crimes
were connected to helping him that's not
the same as obama
there's a debate about pardons to be had
let's not pretend
that what donald trump has done with
pardons is the same
as what barack obama did of the 65
pardons and commutations
that trump had granted before yesterday
60 went to people either with a personal
tie to donald trump
or whose crimes specifically helped
trump's political goals
or helped to protect donald trump so
that's different
now trump and other trump loyalists have
insisted the president's pardon power is
absolute
and in a general sense that's absolutely
true the pardon power is absolute
but remember that trump dangled a pardon
for paul manafort
during manafort's prosecution that's
part of the obstruction that robert
mueller was looking at among other
instances recall that
during paul manafort's trial trump
publicly praised
manafort didn't rule out a pardon even
as the trial was ongoing
and then said manafort was brave for
refusing to break
and that flipping almost ought to be
outlawed
and then of course bigger picture the
the other tragedy with this
is that there are really
at least thousands of people maybe tens
of thousands i don't know
not trump's cronies but just regular
people mistreated by the justice system
who could really benefit from pardons
and trump is throwing in a few pardons
for people
serving long jail sentences for drug
charges for example but
it's really symbolic and meaningless
systemically and structurally
and if trump really wanted to do
something good
with this pardon power look at the
hundreds or even thousands of people
bullied unfairly by the justice system
convicted for drug crimes which have now
ruined their employment prospects
who could really benefit from a pardon
so always with trump
it's not just the cronyistic stuff and
the nepotism
but there's almost always a missed
opportunity to actually use his power
for good
expect even more pardons we're still
waiting to see whether the pre-emptive
pardons
happen for his family for rudy giuliani
and others
that may not be until january if it does
happen
on january 1st huge membership special
to kick off the year if you've been
thinking of getting a membership
get on my newsletter at davidpakman.com
you will get a perfect email on the
first telling you how to sign
up the david pakman show at
davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is magic spoon
the reason i'm such a fan of magic spoon
is they allow me to enjoy the delicious
breakfast cereals i loved as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon
makes breakfast cereal that you really
can't tell apart from those tasty sugary
cereals that we all know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of
protein so it's perfect for someone on a
low carb
keto diet just anybody trying to eat
healthier and cut back on the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing
and magic spoon now lets you create your
own customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100 percent of your money if you
don't love it
no questions asked go to magicspoon.com
pacman to build your own custom variety
box today
make sure to use promo code pacman to
get free shipping
the link is right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so as we're going to talk about a little
bit later today donald trump left
washington dc yesterday after vetoing
the second coronavirus relief bill
and appears to be turning on absolutely
everyone around him including vice
president mike pence
and things are going to get interesting
for these last few weeks uh based on a
report from axios's jonathan swann
it appears that the reason trump is
turning on everybody
is fury and rage that others are not
indulging trump's conspiracy theories
about the election
nor his absolutely hopeless and absurd
ideas for how to overturn the results
donald trump has reportedly been
outraged at vice president mike pence
at chief of staff mark meadows at white
house council
pat chipoloni at secretary of state mike
pompeo and even at
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
and even though
once again the white house and the
people around trump have distanced
themselves from attorney sidney powell
it appears as though it's her
perspective that's the one that is in
trump's mind primarily
which is that everybody around him who's
not willing to foment his harebrained
ideas
for how to overturn the election are
seen by trump as being weak
stupid or disloyal or some combination
of the three
and the effect of this again according
to jonathan swan from axios
is that the few people around trump with
an iota of common sense
are reportedly very concerned about
donald trump's behavior
donald trump reportedly thinks mike
pence isn't fighting hard enough for him
donald trump is furious that white house
counsel pat cipolloni
isn't doing enough of the things trump
wants to try
to overturn the election trump thinks
anyone who's not willing to push for the
department of justice
to forcibly see i'm sorry the uh it's
not justice it's um
homeland security to forcibly seize
voting machines anybody who doesn't want
that is weak
and apparently it's not just trump
cultists and loyalists who are looking
at january 6th
as an important date because according
to people who have discussed
january 6 with donald trump he is also
apparently thinking that maybe mike
pence can do
something for him as he oversees the
formal counting
of the electoral vote donald trump spoke
monday night with republicans in the
house about voting to
overturn the results on january 6th
which is just completely absurd and then
lastly
it does appear that donald trump has
also fully turned on senate
majority leader republican senator mitch
mcconnell
including listen to this trump had his
own personal assistant
email uh republican lawmakers
on monday night a single powerpoint
slide
that attacks mitch mcconnell so there's
every indication that the last
couple of weeks of this administration
after we get back
uh from from the new year's break are
going to be
completely and utterly insane the
grifters
and the conspiracy theorists really seem
to have gotten to donald trump and and
trump
actually seems to have fallen for all of
the craziest ideas and the most
laughable notions about this election
and about how
he could potentially overturn the
results and get a second term
none of which will work but will
embarrass him and really damage the
the country if he continues to try and
so
if the last few weeks are evidence of
anything they're evidence that that 25th
amendment to remove a president
would never have been more appropriate
than it is right now but
it's not even worth talking about more
it's just not going to happen
the themes here are trump can never
accept responsibility
he can never accept losing everything is
always
somebody else's fault he can never
accept
that his actions have consequences he
sees the consequences
but he doesn't connect them to his past
actions he he blames other people
and by the time we get back early in
2021
there's sort of two paths here donald
trump will either have continued
escalating from this to something even
more outrageous
or he won't come back to the white house
at all
after his christmas trip to florida and
he'll just sort of evaporate
the way he's been behaving the last 48
hours makes me think he's not going to
go quietly
but all we can do is wait and see but
republicans
are increasingly worried about his
behavior and i want to talk about that
next donald trump dropped an absolutely
massive chaos bomb just
massive dumps of chaos before leaving
washington dc for his florida resort
yesterday
we already discussed that trump vetoed
the second coronavirus relief package
trump tweeted threats to iran and trump
continues to make completely baseless
claims
about supposed voter fraud and now
republicans in the house and senate are
apparently trying to figure out
how to deal with what they are
increasingly describing
as an unhinged trump and of course with
all of these stories we have to
understand the backstory
but we also need to understand that
although it may
sound as if these republicans now
accurately
are describing what's going on with
trump they've been the primary enablers
of trump
uh for a very long time and trump has
been unhinged and continues being
unhinged
so the republicans now saying whoa
trump's acting a little bit crazy
they deserve none of our sympathy and
they deserve much of the blame
now i already told you in the earlier
segment that donald trump's behavior
with regard to trying to overturn the
election has put him at odds with his
own vice president mike pence
his own secretary of state his own white
house counsel
and many other people now we're hearing
from many sources that
aids around donald trump at the white
house are increasingly disturbed by his
anti-democratic behavior
but since trump posted that absurd video
screed on tuesday making all sorts of
false claims
about the stimulus package and after he
dropped that chaos bomb
yesterday before leaving we're hearing
from more and more republicans and aides
to republicans that there is
genuine concern about what trump is
doing here
one republican aide said to cnn that
trump is quote coming
unhinged now he's been unhinged for
years uh
house republicans actually had a phone
call yesterday
to talk about what to do about donald
trump's bizarre threats
and his reaction to the stimulus package
which of course ended up with a veto as
we already discussed
republican congressman don bacon says
trump has thrown republicans under the
bus
and there are apparently also concerns
that some republicans
will bow to trump's pressure to try to
challenge the counting of the electoral
vote
on january 6. now to be clear nobody
thinks that they would have enough
support to actually make a difference
and overturn
the results mitch mcconnell has been
telling senate republicans
do not get involved in this effort to
challenge the results
on january 6th but there's concern about
how to handle the optics if some
republicans
did bow to donald trump's pressure so
let's talk a little bit more
about that there's no way that
republicans are going to
change the outcome of the electoral
college vote
going for joe biden but it is
conceivable
that trump will get some house
republicans to object to the count
for joe biden to get electoral votes
from
six states that biden won and if house
republicans
and trump can convince just a single
republican senator
to join them in their objections
theoretically
they could force a vote in both chambers
which republicans and democrats
still believe would lead to joe biden
winning but again it would look
disastrous for republicans in a number
of different ways
those who might vote to give trump the
presidency
if such a vote were forced would be
completely
humiliated nationally and those who vote
that biden should be president
republicans might suffer the wrath of
trumpists
in their constituencies now increasingly
i'm getting the sense
that even though these very republicans
are the people responsible for what
donald trump did over the last four
years
they likely are setting themselves up at
least many of them
to sort of pretend they were never
really on trump's side
even to pretend trump sort of didn't
happen after donald trump leaves office
and to very quickly move on and get back
to
partisan business as usual we care about
the debt
we ca we have to stop socialism we have
to stop government takeovers of this
that and the other things but
before that happens prepare yourselves
for a very very wacky few weeks
and we'll have more coverage of this on
the show's
instagram at davidpakmanshow uh and make
sure you're following me on instagram as
well
at david.pakman we'll take a quick break
and we will be speaking to
mark tuschnet after the break do we
really need the supreme
court a very interesting perspective
from mark tuschner coming up
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money
helping the environment but it's
actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love
it only took a few minutes to set up
really easy and it's been a totally
different experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about half
as much
water nebia also offers a number of
shower accessories like shelves and
curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
pacman and use code pacman will get 15
off all nebia products
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
today we're going to be speaking
with mark tuschnet who is emeritus
professor at harvard law school and also
a specialist in u.s
and comparative constitutional law uh
it's so great to have you on i really
appreciate it
thanks for having me so i guess to get
into this conversation
there's been significant debate over the
last few months since the passing of
supreme court justice ruth bader
ginsburg
about uh the correct number of supreme
court justices and questions like
whether there should for example be a
term limits for supreme court justices
but
there's another approach and that's one
of questioning whether
we really even need or or should have a
supreme court so i mean let's let's just
start there
what do you believe the purpose of the
supreme court
was originally and does it still fulfill
that purpose
well the basic idea of the court was
that you needed some body
that would be able to enforce
the provisions of the constitution
[Music]
you could expect politicians to debate
the constitutional issues and
reach compromises and so on and so
uh politics might be one way of making
sure that
uh people adhere to the constitution but
uh um early on people started worrying
that politicians might find it in their
mutual interest to do something that was
inconsistent with the constitution
to agree on oh
some program that gave the president too
much power
sure or more likely that we
of what we think of today uh enact
programs that violated individual rights
and the thought was you could insert a
court
into the process so as to
to check against those possibilities
and at this point in time is that
number one still necessary and number
two
is that the primary activity that the
supreme court is engaged in
checking that well on the second
question no actually it turns out not
the primary
thing the court does things that don't
get
as much attention is interpret statutes
uh tell you know congress passes a
statute
it's got some provisions in it that
aren't clear
uh and and the supreme court comes up
with an
authoritative interpretation of the
statute
um on the first um
i think it's it's a tricky question
about
whether the court is um
now either needed or doing too much
in terms of enforcing
constitutional provisions the reason
it's tricky
is that we now understand that there's
a lot of that would put it this way
reasonable disagreement
about what the constitution actually
means
and it's everybody thinks they know
the constitution prohibits things that
they don't like
happening but it turns out that
it's very difficult to say
that very often legislators or
congress president actually do things
that
nobody could fairly say are
consistent with the constitution
occasionally they do
once in a while but most of the time
what the court's doing
is saying you have this interpretation
of the constitution
maybe it's a reasonable one but we have
a different one
and we're going to stop you from doing
what
you think is consistent with the
constitution
so in terms of uh yeah no prof so in
term in terms of
if there were no supreme court is it is
it as simple as
the the the next lowest court's decision
it becomes the final decision is it that
simple or is there more rearranging that
would need to be done
well you'd probably want to do more
rearranging i mean
what if it were if you just took the
court out of the process entirely
then you'd end up with the possibility
of
a court in california saying something
constitutionally okay
and a court in massachusetts saying it's
not okay
yeah that's not impossible i mean you
can live with a world like that
but it's sort of awkward we think it's
our constitution
so you probably if you take the court
out of the process you probably
want to take the lower courts out of it
as well
and how would you do that would you
establish some kind of a
well i mean i won't i won't even pretend
to know how you would do it how would it
be done what would what would be the way
that you would rearrange that process
well my preferred solution would be to
say yes we can still keep the courts
involved
for reasons that i'll get to in just a
moment but
they should apply a standard we could
even write it into the constitution
that they should hold things
unconstitutional only if they are
my phrase is manifestly unreasonable
uh and and that sharply reduces
the uh degree to which the courts
any court could uh uh could
intervene in in constitutional
interpretation it would still give them
some role
but only for extreme cases
in terms of the more common reforms that
are sometimes mentioned or changes to
the court
things like changes to the process by
which
by the mere chance or timing of who is
president
at the time that a vacancy is created
changing that
so it's not just the the whim of whether
there's a republican or a democrat in
the white house
changing the number of justices on the
court putting term limits
for being on the court do you do you
like any of these
all of them none of them um
so i'm in favor of sort of any program
that's
likely to have some effect on reducing
the role of the court in our political
life
okay uh people the most popular thing
the
of the things you've mentioned are term
limits
and um i'm i've signed on to a term
limits proposal
people who favor them do think that
if you have sort of a regular process of
um arrival and departure
then the stakes for each
appointment will go down and that might
lower the uh willingness of the court to
get involved in deep
political matters the appointment
process would be more routine less
highly politicized
i think that might happen um
the the expanding the size of the court
which is also something i currently
favor uh would
temporarily actually make the court more
prominent uh
because people would focus on on well
they've just
you know expanded the court to change
the rulings that
are coming out of it but people also
seem to think that
eventually there'd be some sort of uh
equilibrium where first democrats expand
the court then republicans expand
the court and eventually people come to
understand that that's not a
terrible terribly great way of doing
things
and what you really want to do is uh
again
lower the temperature of the court's
activity
and so you know they people talk about
reducing the legitimacy of the court i
think that's basically a good thing
uh and so if court expansion had that
effect
that would be okay with me too when it
comes to
um the idea of uh and i know that
this is sort of a different different
question the idea of constitutional
originalism which is a very very big
debate
to me there's a few elements that that
sort of don't pass the sniff test
that are very often mentioned and i'm
curious to get your thoughts on it one
is
if we're talking about constitutional
originalism
as thought at the time of the
constitution's creation when we talk
about
bearing arms we would have to account
for the types of arms that existed at
the time and recognize a lot of what's
available today
would be out of scope even even
theoretically imaginable at the time
when you talk about cruel and unusual
punishment what we have today is is
dramatically different than what would
have
fallen under that definition at the time
so how
what is your sense in terms of this
debate around originalism
which is often put forward by those who
seem unwilling to concede
some of these points on cruel and
unusual and on the second amendment that
i've brought up
uh i think we have to distinguish
between
two kinds of originalism there's
the originalism that academics have come
up with
okay uh and academics have a decent
account
of uh academic originalists have
have come up with a decent account of
the second amendment problems
and how we can deal with them
uh and the cruel and unusual president
provision
and a whole bunch of other things uh
equality for women
uh is a you know significant matter
so the academic theory actually has a
certain amount of
credibility but then there's the
practice of originalism
by judges who say they are originalists
and that's sharply different from what
the academics say
and it's entirely inconsistent they are
originalists when
the results they come up with uh
fit their mostly conservative ideology
and then they depart from originalism
when
they haven't figured out how to
defend their conservative positions
in originalist terms uh the best example
of that incidentally is affirmative
action
um uh there's there's just no
uh uh no credible
the academics have a credible way of
defending or
attacking affirmative action uh uh on
originalist grounds
but conservative judges haven't even
bothered to try
they just think that it's inconsistent
with some
fundamental principle of equality that
they're committed to
without trying to link that principle to
original
understandings okay this is good because
it adds a level of nuance when we hear
those who
are not particularly well educated on
this bring up this issue of
of original intent in order to defend
some of their
conservative ideals so when we talk
about constitutional originalism you're
pointing out
there is judicial constitutional
originalism
and then there is academic
constitutional originalism and that
these are two different things and
as you're putting forward the idea that
academic constitutional originalism
does deal with some of these apparent
contradictions maybe we could dig into
one of them like for example
on second amendment and the idea of what
arms referred to
hundreds of years ago versus the weapons
available today
how would the academic originalists sort
of deal with that
so the academic account is actually
there are two versions of the academic
account
one is um tied to
what we mostly think about these days
and
it is uh you say
you have to think about the kinds of
weapons
that people had in mind that were
understood to be covered by the
second amendment right and
when they thought about and talked about
the weapons that were covered by the
second amendment they referred to
weapons that everybody has access to
or in the current phrase weapons and
common use
and so now you translate that to the
current
circumstances and you ask what weapons
are in current use today
um so so weapons and current use then
were muskets and
things like that they're not in current
use now but
ordinary handguns are in current use um
on the other hand
bazookas are not in current use so
you're making an analogy in other words
you have to you have to think of
what was what would be analogous to
those weapons
today yeah okay exactly um
so that's one way of doing it sure the
other way is much more radical and
actually i think my own view is uh more
connected to
what was actually going on um the
original understanding on this second
view of the second amendment was
that it was a way of ensuring
that ordinary people would be able
to fight against
an overreaching government
they would be able to arm themselves to
protect themselves
not against criminals right but against
you know soldiers
um and given what the military has today
that would imply a very very high a
loose
standard for what it would mean for
exactly and
no no contemporary defender of the
second amendment except
people associated with you know these
michigan militia types
want to go there um and so the judges
uh say well we don't you know they may
have had this original understanding
about
what was called the insurrectionist view
but
but that's not what we think the
original understanding was
and they do that precisely for this sort
of
um instrumental reason
ends focused reasons they don't want to
say
people have a right to have bazookas or
anti-tank weapons
right now it seems like you could apply
a similar standard to this idea of cruel
and unusual punishments right where
where you would say well just because
there are things available now that
weren't available then and some of the
things that were done then have gone out
of style
we have to sort of evaluate what is
analogous at this time
right right and and and here
in fact um again the academic position
is yeah that's right and it might be
that in particular capital punishment
or uh life in prison
without parole for juveniles those might
be
inconsistent with the fundamental ideas
that were understood
to be written into the cruel and unusual
punishment
punishments clause and again what
judicial originalists do is they abandon
the originalism
and they say well look the text says
capital crimes so whatever
they thought cruel and unusual
punishment meant they
also thought capital punishment was
constitutionally permissible um and and
so again you see this inconsistency
between
the practice of conservative judges who
want to uphold capital punishment
and um originalism
as it might be coherently worked out
absolutely fascinating i think the big
takeaway is
no matter what you call your philosophy
there is still debate to be had in
figuring out exactly how
we define it and and different versions
of it
uh uh that's right i mean uh i think
the the again i'm an academic the
academic view of these debates
is that with relatively
minor exceptions um
whatever your theoretical position is
you're going to be able to fit your
current
political views into it
and that means that the theoretical
stuff really
really isn't doing any serious work
what's going on is you're a liberal or
you're conservative
and that's how you rule yes uh very well
described by
by behavioral economists in fact like
daniel kahneman
and and others who have talked a lot
about that type of uh
motivated reasoning which clearly exists
within the issue of of constitutional
scholarship as well
uh we've been speaking with mark tushnet
emeritus professor at harvard law school
uh professor it's been such a pleasure
speaking with you i so appreciate your
time
i i enjoyed it and appreciate being on
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in
15 minutes blinkist makes sure that
you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for if
there's a full book you're thinking
about buying
you can use blinkist to get a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
2020 has really been a comedy of errors
for fox news host maria bartiromo but
yesterday something truly magical
happened
she interviewed the supposed ceo of a
pork producer and processor
the ceo supposedly named dennis organ
from smithfield foods
and it turns out that she wasn't really
interviewing dennis oregon but instead
it was an animal rights activist named
matt johnson from the organization
direct action everywhere and this is
amazing to watch and it's kind of like
the cherry on top in these last few days
of 2020
of what has been a completely
humiliating year for maria bartoromo
brown
nosing donald trump endlessly claiming
without evidence or vetting last week
that a so-called intel
source assured her trump really did win
the 2020 election
doing pathetic softball interview after
softball interview with donald trump
so anyway let's get to this interview
supposedly with pork ceo dennis oregon
actually an activist named matt johnson
the topic is vaccines
for food workers another group pushing
to get the vaccine early food workers
plants across the u.s are major
outbreaks early in the pandemic
joining me right now is the ceo of
smithfield foods dennis organ dennis
it's great to have you this morning
thanks very much for joining us can you
tell us where you are in terms of that
rash of chronovirus cases
that hit your south dakota operation
uh well merry christmas maria uh thank
you so much for having me on
uh i mean it's certainly been been a
challenging time
um and and we have our our workers
uh that are you know in desperate need
of these vaccinations and as you
mentioned uh
we're heartened to hear that the cdc is
prioritizing america's food workers
um with the second round of vaccinations
um
it's a 30 million vaccine doses that are
going out
to essential frontline employees out of
the 87 million total
and um of course this pandemic has been
simply devastating for our industry
thousands of our um really courageous
food workers and i really do want to
emphasize
uh the the heroic efforts of these folks
um they've been getting sick for
you know really just trying to provide
for their families
um and as far as smithfield you know
what we've
we've done for our employees we've
provided them with extensive personal
protective equipment
and offered additional um paid leave for
for sick
employees but um the steps have have
unfortunately been uh insufficient in in
many instances
these folks have been through a lot
frankly we might bear some
responsibility
for that but we know that our smithfield
family is is dedicated
so it starts pretty buttoned up but then
uh uh he starts with
you know we probably bear some
responsibility for food workers catching
covid
and it starts to slowly get wackier and
it's not clear maria bartiromo realizes
it right away
and and resilient and and the better
times uh
are ahead um and if i may add quickly um
as as as the new uh ceo and president of
smithfield
um i'm personally promised that uh that
we're gonna do better
um and and the first change uh under my
leadership is
is transparency and and at times brutal
honesty and
um and and the truth is that our
industry in addition to the outbreaks
that are happening at our plants
our industry poses a serious threat um
in in effectively
bringing on the next pandemic um
with cdc data um showing that
three or four infectious diseases come
from from animals
um and the conditions inside of inside
of our farms can sometimes be petri
dishes
uh for for new diseases um hog farming
also causes immense harm to our hair and
waterways
so now he goes into bullet points about
how terrible animal agriculture is
and how it contributes to pollution and
to carbon emissions and it's obviously
not what a pork ceo
would ever say and i can't tell but
maybe maria is starting to think
something is up here
and there's more and maria seems so
eager to talk about how smithfield farms
was bought by a chinese conglomerate
that she almost seems not to notice
but then matt johnson starts bringing up
more animal-born
diseases and it starts to become almost
satirical
and then he starts talking about a 500 a
500 million dollar donation take a
listen
well dennis that's what i want to ask
you about that's what i want to ask you
about dennis because smithfield foods is
the world's
largest pork producer you are in an
incredible
you know uh an incredible spot
uh to have incredible impact in the
united states and across the world but
china acquired smithfield your parent
company is now based in hong kong
uh can you tell us how it works there
was a post recently
uh about the way your company operates
are the
hogs raised in the united states and
then sent to china
uh to get slaughtered and and uh and uh
produced and and packaged
yeah well smithfield foods uh is uh
uh owned by a chinese conglomerate um
and
uh the the pigs are uh they're
slaughtered in the us and and uh we we
have an export market which
we think is uh a very necessary part of
a thriving economy to have open trade
um there is um
so it's been some leveling off of demand
that we've seen in china
um there was a african swine fever
outbreak that happened
um or or a round of them really um
where there was greater demand
dennis i was told that in china you know
there was this african swine flu
that affected so many pigs that there
were a million pigs in the river
dead they didn't know where to where to
get rid of the pigs that were dead and
then other sources were saying well
you know you can't get sick even if the
pig was uh
had african swine flu if the pig was
dead so they
they cut up the meat as well how are
americans
going to believe that the meat is safe
if they're going to china to get
slaughtered and packaged what kind of
processing
securities do you have in place to
assure
americans that their pork is safe tennis
yeah yeah absolutely so we we have
extensive
uh safety protocols in place uh for our
essential frontline employees
um from from personal protective
equipment that they wear
to uh to sanitation of of all of our
equipment and our facilities
and uh i mean i think that uh that our
company's track record
really speaks for itself um in in that
regard but
um i mean in terms of the impact that
we've that
this industry has on on the world um
we really want to to to kind of embrace
a brighter future
and um and and with
um and with with some of the the the
impacts uh that our industry is is
having
um we are actually pledging now um a
half a billion dollars a year starting
in 2021
to to mitigate some of these impacts
because um what's happening
in china um and what's happening
elsewhere
um there's a lot of concerns a lot of
people are worried about hilariously
maria bartoromo
almost knowingly is uh almost
unknowingly is indicting smithfield as
much as the fake ceo
is but his mention of pledging half a
billion dollars
500 million to fighting the very
problems his company creates
is just brilliant and then they ended up
finding out after the fact
that this was completely bogus and maria
bartoromo
found out it was a fake ceo and she
apologized we have an important
correction to make it appears we have
been punked earlier in the program i
interviewed someone calling
claiming to be the ceo of smithfield
foods dennis organ
we've since learned that that was not
dennis organ but an imposter making
false claims about the company
he is someone who has absolutely no
relation to smithfield foods
we want to apologize to dennis organ
smithfield foods and to our audience
for making this mistake we will of
course be more
vigilant it is just wild and this is a
great opportunity to play a clip that
many may not know about i would be doing
you a disservice
if i didn't take this opportunity to
play a clip
of when max rice who's been a guest on
this show
max rice pretended back in 2012
to be a former obama voter so
disillusioned with obama that he was
voting mitt romney in 2012
and he pranked then-fox news anchor
gretchen carlson on fox news
i would argue it was better than
yesterday's smithfield prank
take a look and apologies for the poor
video quality
to the romney ryan ticket joining me now
is a recent college grad
max rice he voted for president obama
now he's
unemployed and just moved out of his
parents
home good morning to you max hello miss
miss usa it's an honor
uh miss america i wish i could see you
but close enough it's america
this universe in my book in my book oh
okay well well thank you very much
um now tell me your story you believed
in the hope and change of president
obama and so you voted for him and
and tell me about the next three i was
huge obama supporter in 2008
i met him in third grade and when i was
little
okay and why now are you supporting me
what's your question why now are you
supporting mitt romney uh
why am i supporting romney it's actually
a funny story
i lost a basketball game to a friend of
mine
alex during he's a huge supporter of the
show
okay so it sounds like you're not being
very smart i'm also i'm also
disappointed in
the direction that obama has taken this
nation but yeah i will be casting my
ballot for mitt romney
okay and uh true that you had to go back
and live with your parents after you
graduated from college
oh yeah after i went to college for a
bit i have to go back and live my
parents this summer i'm back on my own
independent i'm on national tv i feel
like i'm doing good
it's an honor okay
well are you being serious about this
interview or not
yeah okay i can't see your face right
now this is so weird
all right well actually we're gonna wrap
this up now because i'm not so sure that
you're actually oh we are
totally serious about that wait wait
wait wait wait
why not yeah i'm not sure
i'm not sure that you're ready for for
prime time yet with this
i'm not ready for prom time wait i've
been this is i've been
all right we're going to give max
another chance maybe when he's ready
so that's really the standard by which
all of these must be judged
and max rice back in 2012 on fox news
was an absolute classic
maria bartoromo yes humiliating herself
with the fake pork ceo
but doing it in marginally less dramatic
fashion
than uh what happened with gretchen
carlson back in 2012 but nicely done
by matt johnson we have a
subreddit discussion forum where you can
join
26 000 other viewers and listeners
and discuss politics respectfully you
can find it at davidpakman.com
reddit few notable posts i spotted this
morning one is a user asking whether we
are going to get to 4 000 daily deaths
from the virus after christmas or new
year's i've said before that i believe
the case peak is coming very
soon and that the death peak is slightly
behind that and that then we are going
to
start seeing warming weather and
vaccinations starting to have an
impact probably by late january early
february so i believe we are almost
at the the pandemic peak unless
something goes very wrong
um i hope we don't get to 4 000 daily
deaths we are regularly seeing 3 300
3 400 now more than a 911's worth of
deaths every day
um it's it's conceivable we will get to
4
000. i'm hopeful that we will not
uh because that would be an absolutely
uh a tragic tragic milestone
but it's not inconceivable another user
of reminding us that new york has
enacted automatic voter registration
this is a topic we've been discussing
for a very long time
the idea that in order to vote you need
to do something beyond simply
being a citizen is antithetical to the
way many voting systems are set up in
other countries undocumented immigrants
by their nature can't vote because
they're not citizens
uh this is not something that uh is
unique to the united states and yet we
have this process here which serves only
to dissuade people from voting or
prevent people from voting
which is even though you could vote you
can't vote
unless you register to vote some states
allowing same-day registration many
not allowing it new york state has
enacted automatic
voter registration the details are
still being sifted through but that is
very
very good news more states should do it
and then lastly because we're wrapping
up here before the holiday
we got a holiday greeting via the
subreddit holiday greetings to david and
pat with much thanks
thanks for maintaining continued
surveillance of the events of this past
year
including the horrendous coveted
pandemic and the equally disgusting
trump and republican machinations
revolving around the election as someone
who has increasingly tuned out much of
the news i nevertheless have great
respect for those who can face what's
been going on
and report and comment about it it's not
an easy task
knowledge can be disheartening but also
empowering
hope next year ends on a higher note for
all of us but whatever the case
hope the pacman show will endure a
beautiful message
and you can join the discussion at
davidpakman.com
reddit all right we have a voicemail
number that number is 2192 david p
we heard from the eggman who mostly
listens to the show
but he watched the other day and it
sounds like he kind of liked it take a
listen
yeah hey dave you know i just listened
to your podcast
i don't watch videos or youtube or any
clips or anything um
i'm an adult i'm busy all day right i
have time to listen while i work
i've been missing out on the visual
aspect oh my god
i just watched a clip on facebook and
you're listening to some crazy caller
and you take a sip of your water
with your hand underneath the cup like
trump did and i started cracking up and
i thought
how many other purely visual jokes am i
missing from you
dave have i been just only getting two
dimensions of the three-dimensional show
yes oh man i've been missing out shalom
brother and um
you know have a really good time off
good holiday season yeah
there are uh many visual elements that
you were missing if you were only
listening to the show but i understand
lots of people prefer just to listen and
that's
absolutely fine we have the audio
podcast for that reason
on the bonus show today the u.s
government has figured out how to get
100 million more vaccine doses from
pfizer we will discuss it
new york is leading the nation in
population
decline and they may lose two house
seats as a result
and the texas lieutenant governor who
offered a million bucks if you can find
evidence of voter fraud is now refusing
to pay it after we found evidence
of pro-trump voter fraud happening uh we
covered that story yesterday we will
discuss the follow uh the fallout on
today's bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpackman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
magic spoon is the cereal that tastes
exactly like the delicious cereals from
your childhood except it has no sugar
tons of protein and only three net carbs
so it's perfect for a keto diet
to get free shipping go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman nebia is
a revolutionary showerhead that saves
you money by using
45 less water but with a stream of water
that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person
by letting you read or listen to an
entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free and get
25
off a subscription by going to
blinkist.com
david pakman